So kann Eis klingen.
Hier wird ausschließlich auf
Instrumenten aus Eis gespielt.
Es ist das eisigste Musikfestival Europas
und vermutlich das abgelegenste.
Euromaxx-Reporter Hendrik Welling hat sich
auf den Weg nach Finse gemacht.
Hier gibt es keine Straßen, keine Autos
– nur einen Bahnhof,
ein paar Ferienhäuser und
sehr viel Eis und Schnee.
Finse liegt im Süden Norwegens in 1222
Metern Höhe
auf halber Bahnstrecke zwischen
Bergen und Oslo,
umgeben von Gletschern, Eis und Schnee.
Ist das hier wirklich der ideale Ort für ein
Musikfestival?
Im vergangenen Jahr fielen die Temperaturen
auf minus 27 Grad Celsius.
Ausgedacht hat sich das Festival Terje
Isungset.
Der Norweger hat vor 20 Jahren zufällig
entdeckt, wie Eis klingen kann.
Ich habe mich sofort in den
fantastischen Klang verliebt,
außerdem sieht es sehr schön aus.
Also dachte ich, es wäre toll,
ein Festival zu organisieren
und viele kreative Leute einzuladen
und zu schauen, was man aus Eis
und Schnee machen kann.
Wir haben nur eine Regel: Eis und Schnee
müssen immer im Spiel sein.
An Eis mangelt es hier nicht.
Ab Dezember gehen die Festivalmacher
immer wieder auf den zugefrorenen See
Finsevatnet.
Hier werden die Eisblöcke herausgesägt,
aus denen später die Instrumente
geschnitzt werden.
Neun Tonnen haben sie über die Monate
geerntet.
An jeder Stelle des Sees kann das Eis
eine andere Qualität haben.
Es gibt verschiedene Eistypen.
Es liegt immer daran, wie das Wasser fließt,
wenn es gefriert.
Und das ist entscheidend für den Klang.
Das hier ist sehr klar und
hat keine Luftblasen.
Damit wird man schöne
Töne machen können.
Innerhalb weniger Stunden bauen die Musiker
ihre Instrumente.
Terje Isungset kreiert ein Element
für eine Marimba aus Eis.
Und jetzt möchte ich einen
höheren Ton haben.
Erstaunlich!
Man kann eigentlich alle Arten
von Instrumenten bauen,
aber am interessantesten finde ich
irgendwelche Fantasie-Instrumente
– oder zumindest die, die keine reine Kopie
von bestehenden Instrumenten sind.
Dieses Instrument will Hendrik Welling
auf jeden Fall ausprobieren.
Es ist eine Art Saxofon aus Eis,
das der norwegische Jazzmusiker
Kjetil Møster kreiert hat
– schwierig zu bauen und noch schwieriger
zu spielen.
Das ist so anstrengend!
Aber einen Ton habe ich zumindest
herausbekommen, oder?
Und so soll es eigentlich klingen ...
Die Besucher kommen aus
der ganzen Welt angereist,
um eines oder mehrere
der acht Konzerte zu besuchen.
Für uns ist es die Erfüllung
eines Lebenstraums.
Ich komme aus Italien.
Aus Italien? Und Sie sind extra für das
Eismusikfestival hierher gekommen?
Ja, weil ich es beeindruckend
und unglaublich finde.
Die Zuschauer sitzen
bei eisiger Kälte im Schnee.
Daher dauern die Konzerte oft nicht länger
als eine Dreiviertelstunde.
Ob Percussion- oder Blasinstrumente:
Es sind oft die leisen Töne,
die die Zuschauer berühren.
Nach drei Tagen
beim Eismusikfestival in Norwegen
geht es für Hendrik Welling wieder nach
Hause.
Was bleibt, sind seine Eindrücke
von der Landschaft und der Eismusik,
die hier perfekt harmonieren.